so welcome to parallelization of code in
Python for beginners today I'm going to
talk about how parallelization helps
computation on data run faster
there are many use cases for this I've
listed some below
the first you can see large data set
pre-processing or processing so whenever
you have you know a number of
Transformations filters operations Etc
are being applied to a large data set
I'm just going record by record if you
will a batch by batch another example uh
expensive function calls so training
perhaps multiple machine learning models
at once is an example of that so hyper
parameter tuning use case for data
scientists
um you also have potentially batch
scoring uh online machine learning
models or any kind of function where it
accepts just one record at a time but
you want to do more than that faster
um can use parallelization to speed that
up as well
but I'll note it's just not a substitute
for vectorizing your code and there's
another talk out there on vectorizing
code what I mean here is in general try
to use built-in functions first from
whatever python package you're using
because these are often built in to
actually leverage existing
parallelization or fast Matrix algebra
packages an example here is numpy and of
course pandas is built on top of numpy
so if there's like a built-in Bend or
Max or what have you try that first and
then you can actually wrap some of these
parallelization functions from joblib
around that
um so it complements that but it doesn't
substitute it
so when can you use parallelization and
how do we recognize those use cases you
can't really use these techniques when
we don't have dependencies across data
or calculations
so certainly low hanging fruit if you
have two tasks you want to execute on
data but they don't depend on each other
then perhaps there's no reason why you
can't run them simultaneously if you
have enough Computing cores on power to
do so
So Below I have three example
quote-unquote graphs of computation to
illustrate potential dependencies and
different jobs you might want to be
running
I'm really sorry uh do you have are you
sharing sites I I don't think yes can
you not see them no I I don't think so I
think if you uh look at the bottom there
all right button
I want to make sure everyone can see
this
yeah I'll just can you see it now like
when I'm flipping between no no no
oh I see I see I didn't hit the prison
desktop
all right share screen
I know this will hopefully oh
okay
I am sorry about that
no that looks good
now you can see it very good
okay so yeah
all right going back to the here's the
graphs of computation uh let me know if
you can't see it uh but on the very left
so we have one example
um of just a pipeline and a pipeline I
mean you're you're running through
different stages in computation
sequentially and the thing about this is
that there might be dependencies between
different stages of computation
different steps
so here I have kind of a modeling
pre-processing example and you know
saying I first want to apply a filter to
select a certain date range of my data
and then after doing that and only after
doing that do I want to apply some kind
of string mashing via a regex filter
well in that case I can't actually
parallelize those two steps because I
only want to do the second step after
the first step
however what I could do is you know in
order to speed up this computation
computation tends to run faster when
you're processing smaller batches of
data so what I could do is I could
actually break up my data set into
multiple chunks and process each chunk
through the pipeline separately
foreign
so a second use case might be this
middle example of model scoring so say I
have some kind of an online model that's
built to just handle one record at a
time
in this case what I could do is you know
it's the same function being applied to
every single record in the data set so
what I could do is I could break the
data sack into you know X many chunks
and then just run my scoring operation
you know on different chunks in parallel
still again recognizing similarities
across the computation and
independencies amongst the data or what
have you
but on a very rightmost side I have um
an anti-example of model training
um in this case you know I really like
to
um say I'm building some expensive you
know long-running machine learning model
I'd really like to be able to
parallelize the learning of that model
on data but unfortunately I often cannot
do this
um and there are a couple reasons for
this
the first is that when I'm training a
model I actually need to make use of the
entire training data set at any given
point in time to learn the weights so
that kind of breaks the dependency the
independency between you know being able
to chunk my data and then run it through
the pipeline or calculations you know in
parallel
um similarly you know there's actually
dependencies between each sequential
step of the of the modeling algorithm
process itself so I can only do you know
step one after step two because the way
that the weights are learned for this
model they actually have to happen in
sequence so you know that makes this an
anti-example
now what kind of techniques do we have
for parallelization where there's pretty
much there's two there's two techniques
multi-threading and multi-processing I
like to explain you know what these
meanings I think these can be kind of
confusing to newcomers
um so these are really doing two
different things so not really
interchangeable
multi-processing indicates a paradigm
for using multiple processors or CPU
cores to execute computation
simultaneously
multi-threading and contrast is dealing
with a single CPU core but executing
computation on that single core faster
and making use of multiple CPU threads
uh you can consider CPU threads as
fundamental units of computation that
are working together to execute a
process a process pin like a Jupiter
notebook you know cell you're executing
a cell you're running a python function
uh you're running python just you know
period
um
so on the leftmost uh schematic we can
see you know the use case for no
parallel processing a single processor
running a single thread
um here you can see this is what the
operating system sees so it's it's
running computation via this thread in
this process the process is the big box
and it needs to allocate some objects to
to execute that computation you don't
really need to understand what these are
the code data file is register in stack
but just be aware that they are taking
up space in memory and the operating
system is using them to run the
computation
on the middle most example we have
multi-threading and in this case again
it's just one big boxes the overall
process but it's been split into
multiple threads which are sharing some
of those objects in memory
and it's speeding up the computation
because you have two threads to execute
the same thing
on the rightmost use case you have
multi-processing and in this scenario it
looks like it's the very leftmost Taste
of the single processor thread being
stuck together and that actually is
what's happening so in this case you
have kind of farmed out two processes to
execute this python function or whatever
it is to different CPU cores on the
middle case that's just running on one
CPU core on the rightmost case you can
actually Farm out these two processes to
different CPU cores
um but as you do that you're actually
duplicating the data in memory that this
operating system needs to execute the
computation
whereas in the multi-threading case
you'd been sharing some of that
[Music]
so multi-processing is kind of safer
because it does wall off these shared
data structures of the operating system
needs it's easier to write you know
multi-processing in that kind of sense
um but it's also kind of potentially
slower because there is that increased
overhead you're duplicating you know
those shared those objects that the
operating system needs multiple times
per process per core
um
so uh multi-preading you know it does
reduce some of that overhead but again
it's kind of trickier to deal with it's
not really appropriate for every uh for
a naive application because you have to
be careful how the threads access that
shared data and it really is kind of
perhaps most effectively deployed by
application developers you have
fine-tuned control over that
so let's uh we need to actually perhaps
delve a bit into the pieces of the
computer that we need to understand to
effectively use a multi-processing and
multi-preading and and the two pieces we
need to understand more about are the
cores and this or CPUs and memory
so the thing you should kind of take
away is that for each CPU core we can
allocate a process in multi-processing
to speed up computation uh so you know
desktop computers today this laptop that
I'm working off here uh has you know
four or more cores so maybe that's a
Forex speed up well not exactly because
there's overhead but that's a general
idea
so what are these processes that we've
been talking to get about again to kind
of reiterate uh processes or Computing
tasks like you know running a python
function or a Jupiter notebook cell
uh brush threads in contrast are
fundamental Computing units of a process
and processes themselves can be
multi-threaded to make computation run
faster or more efficiently
so another example is you have a browser
process and a given thread in that
process might be to control the back or
the forward button another thread might
be to control the scroll bar or to make
some back end data requests to a server
or something
so we can have parallel Computing by
running processes in parallel on
separate CPU cores such as the use case
we're going to focus on
as well you need to consider memory and
the specific memory requirements of your
job so consider again that if you're
doing many tasks in parallel uh that
computation is you know depending on
what it's doing it's creating objects in
memory it's destroying objects it needs
some kind of memory for Scratch base
um as well as that you might be passing
in large and and large arguments to the
inputs of your function
uh that will take up space and memory
and remember that you know in the
multi-processing scenario on the right
here for each core that you parallelize
your computation you're duplicating
those objects across this course so in
an extreme case you know you might run
out of memory and you might actually
crash your computer
um
one note on Linux you can run the top
command to actually see your running
threads and processes
and to kind of clarify what we mean
about multi-processing here
um consider that you have a single core
computer
well if you run top you'll actually see
multiple processes running but that does
not mean that they're multi-processed
you only have one core on your CPU so it
stopped running in parallel what's
actually happening is that the operating
system is switching between all those
processes very quickly
the only way to have parallel Computing
and multi-processing is to actually have
multiple cores
I would recommend actually when you run
job live jobs or parallel Computing that
you do kind of run to top or some other
command to make sure that yes
dependencies are launching as expected
and they haven't died or anything
laughs
so we're going to focus again on using
multi-processing
um because it's we're using drop limits
and the document Drive is also kind of
you know note this that it's they
recommend using multiprocessing it tends
to be easier for wrapping around
blackbox code
um and it you know does suit a fair
amount of use cases given today's
computers having multiple cores
um themselves
you know the caveat again is that if
you're duplicating uh large data in
memory because you need some input data
to be shared not always here but
deployed to multiple cores then you know
that's kind of a downside there's also
more overhead but multiplying again is
much trickier
um in either of these use cases you kind
of have to be aware of are you sharing
data sets or objects among multiple
cores uh certainly you don't want to
write to the same segmented memory for a
shared object that's kind of a gotcha
um so just kind of be aware of when
you're writing to like say a shared
input argument or something
and again again
um so basically the the takeaway is that
multi-processing is kind of easier to
use especially when
um you're wrapping this job live around
a code where it itself is based on some
python library and you're not sure
exactly the inner workings of that that
can make the threading harder as well
so now we're going to go into an example
in joblib the code is available publicly
at this get repo
um what we're going to do here is kind
of illustrate the design choices you
have when you're designing a job live
job how do you actually break up a
single big computational task into many
smaller ones so that you get the
benefits of parallelization
so hopefully you can see my browser yes
you can
um so we're going to be working with uh
kind of like a machine learning workflow
I have two examples here probably just
going to get through but we'll see uh
the first example is kind of dfp
processing and the second is
um hyper parameter tuning uh going to be
working with Amazon Fine Food reviews
data from kaggle it's about 500 000
records
this is what it looks like uh we're
going to actually be carrying about the
text field which is you know a string of
text as well as the score field which is
the user's review of this product this
fine food product on a scale of one to
five
foreign
here's what the text looks like
independent series
um
there is the distribution of the scores
uh five is best and the scores are kind
of weighted towards the higher reviews
of five
now whenever you want to work with text
Data it does tend to be more
computationally expensive and you want
to get a sense of how long that text is
so here I'm just taking the character
length of each review and looking at the
distribution they're fairly short
actually but there is some data skew
towards you know much longer review
texts
that tends to happen in nature
so identifying opportunities from
parallelization again you know with this
pre-processing you're typically going to
be going record by record so that you
know parallelization should immediately
kind of leave to mind in that use case
um
say here I want to do some uh apply some
regex filter regular expression
manipulation of each record of text in
my data set say what I want to do is I
want to remove any sentences that are
related to package delivery and I only
want to focus on the review related to
the product itself
so here I have an example text
um example review liked it the package
right fast the cookies for play key and
tender and what I want to do is to
remove this middle sentence because it's
about package delivery
so what I do is I write a regex to
identify any offending sentences
um and then I write a function that
takes in a string of review text
multiple sentences that regex and goes
ahead and removes the funding sentence
and Returns the cleaned the cleaned
review a text
now without joblib let's see how this
performs
um so here I am just you know applying
that function across my uh text
impounded series of text
um and I'm gonna you know I know this is
kind of an expensive function to do so
I'm not going to try to shove the whole
data set through it at once I want to
see how it scales
um so I you know for a thousand records
it takes only one second for a hundred
thousand it takes two minutes so it
looks like it's scaling linearly by the
number of Records here which is good but
once they get past 500 000 records it
looks like it's slowing down and taking
longer than linearly within number of
Records
um
500.6 000 records takes 13 minutes
and so two things one is that 13 minutes
is kind of too long for me already uh
but the other is that the fact that it's
slowing down
um after around 500 000 records
indicates to me that the more data
Beyond this data size I definitely want
to consider parallelization because it's
going to take longer and longer to
execute that code
so now we get to childlib and they're
embarrassingly simple for Loop solution
so again you know the use case here is
I'm just flipping over each record in my
data set so why not split this amongst
different colors in my computer
and there are two kind of design
parameters you need to consider here
the first is the number of workers that
you want to send computation to or the
number of jobs that's the same thing
um
as well as the chunk size of each job so
you know how big of a data input are you
going to give each worker
how are you going to give each worker a
single record of that pandas series are
you going to give them you know a chunk
of records of that Panda series
um
so a number of jobs or workers is kind
of easy it's going to be the number of
cores on your computer generally you
want to Max that out
um chunk size is kind of trickier and
this is where you want to consider the
memory requirements of uh your job
so again if I was duplicating
um if I had an input argument that was
very big and I was duplicating that in
memory you know four times on my
computer is that going to be a problem
um here I just have my only input
argument besides the text itself is the
regex string that's tiny so I don't have
to worry about that
um but the fact that it is something
that she want to consider
um if you are you know thinking about
the the size of the topic giving each
worker
um the other thing is that the more jobs
uh you spawn
um I could potentially spawn like over
500 000
um you know processes here it's not
going to be a problem it's a lot of
overhead
um it depends on your computer and yeah
you know potentially the job itself so
you're going to want to experiment
[Music]
foreign
so one thing that I do need to do
um to do this experimentation is I'm
going to need to create a functional
wrapper around my original function
because I potentially want to give each
core of my computer an iterable of text
if I want you know to give them a chunk
of say 100 000 records at once
so my original function only took in a
single string and then I applied that
across my panda series but here I just
want to wrap around it a function that's
going to take it an iterable of strings
and then I'm just going to apply across
that iterable moderational function
so it's pretty simple
here you can see the actual childhood
call itself so I have these kind of two
input variables the number of job has
kind of fixed the number of chords of my
computer I guess one note here so I have
an Intel CPU which does have hyper
threading so I have four physical cores
but because each physical core is hyper
threaded to have two virtual cores a
logical course if you will I supposedly
have eight cores but for Joplin purposes
I'm only going to care about the
physical chorus if I specify each year
it's not actually going to speed up my
computation
foreign
as well we have the other parameter the
number of chunks which is going to imply
the chunk size so for me because my data
set is like 500 000 records if I divide
that by four uh this four chunks is
going to imply like 125 000 records per
core at a time
[Music]
so from joblib library I'm going to
import these two functions parallel and
delayed
the inputs to parallel are going to be
inputs related to the actual
parallelization
and jobs is going to be the number of
cores or workers
um four so it's going to be four here
um again I prefer processes uh which is
again also uh preferred by the top Loop
developers is that you go with
multi-processing first in most use cases
you can't actually specify the back end
which will also determine multiple
versus multi-processing
um but they prefer that gelatin devs
preferred that she would instead hint
that you whether you prefer processes or
threads so that's what I'm going to do
here
um and then I'm going to set maximum
verbosity
batch size I just said to auto
um so the output of parallelism itself
can be a function and the input to this
function is going to be the output of
the delayed function
delay it is itself gonna wrap around the
function that feeds a chunk of data or a
single record or what have you to each
of the workers so a given core
um here I'm going to feed it my uh
function that takes into the iterable of
of Records and that itself has its own
arguments which is you know the chunk of
data itself as well as the regex
um
here I'm just splitting up my kind of
series my entire 100 000 records into
four
of say 125 000 each
now with four four workers
um and one chunk each so four chunks
it's going to take me only six minutes
so it's over 50 speed up
um and you can experiment as well uh
with this particular job it didn't
really matter what I picked um it's
always was kind of around six minutes
um here you can see if I do specify my
max number of logical chorus it's not
actually increasing the speeding up
their runtime
but of course if I decrease the number
of workers that I send computation to it
does slow it down
um
and Below joblib has printed out some
stuff for me uh with my maximum
verbosity of 10.
um and you can see here that it really
is executing computation in parallel so
they're working four tasks because I
have four chunks of data
um and the first task finishes in five
and a half minutes but the remaining
three only finish 0.1 minute later so it
really is executing in parallel
so the result of this uh function call
is going to be a list of lists uh the
first layer of list is going to be the
number of chunks the length the length
is going to be done number of chunks and
each chunk is going to have a 140 000
records
uh in it
because then I have to aggregate them up
by just decomposing that list of this
and that takes you know it's really
quick just don't have to worry about
that and then I have my final result
now I could again have actually fed a
single record into job Lab at a time and
have had my four workers cycle through
you know all 500 000 tasks in this case
there's actually it's not that bad for
me to do that I still get a six minute
run time but you can see it really is
launching 500 000 like you know tasks at
once
[Music]
um
so yeah
I think I'm just going to speed through
just really touch on high level of this
hyper parameter tuning example here I
I'm I'm kind of you know class I'm
building a classifier I'm going to build
a GBM to classify scores into High
versus low
um
and instead of parallelizing over data
here I'm going to parallelize over
multiple models at once
so I have this situation where I want to
build multiple versions of the GBM and I
have different hyper parameter
combinations like arguments to the GBM
that I want to test in once so I end up
with 54 combinations each model takes
about a minute to run and if I you know
if I go through that one by one it's
going to take me like an hour
um but I can parallelize it with joblib
same technique
um and I get front time only half an
hour
which is great
um but I might be more of a chair like
so I'm I have this huge input argument
my training data set right am I going to
be it's going to be a problem for me to
be duplicating that four times in memory
across my course
actually no because this happens to be a
panda's data frame which is based on
numpy and droplip has this thing built
into it where it's going to pass large
numpy arrays by reference so it's not
actually duplicating it in memory
um this is great if I'm just passing in
like you know read-only or things that
are just going to be read but of course
if you're writing to a large empire
right be aware that if you end up
writing to it that's that construct your
data but here it's definitely an
advantage
um
it allows me to speed up my model
training
so
that's my example
um
I could suppose I could I just have a
few more kind of tips and tricks uh
Oops I did do that right
so some gotchas again avoid writing to
overlapping segments of data and memory
um
there's that shared numpy data caveat
and read the documentation here
um on the job of the page
the other is multi-processing and
multi-threading uh generally it works
and especially if you're using the
low-key back end but there can be some
edge cases
um as well I would note that
multi-processing calls to external
servers may not be a good idea because
the servers themselves have their own
mechanisms for handling multiple
requests so your calls may go into a
queue anyways negating any effects of
multiple calls
um and then I said just some tips and
tricks uh start out small and see how
runtime scales
um
the one frustrating thing can be if your
job crashes it's likely because you've
run out of memory in some form
so there's kind of a balance of things
you want to tune the number of jobs or
and or the job and the job size
essentially try increasing the number of
tasks potentially
um within reason if you're doing that
you're feeding smaller chunks of data to
a single worker at a time but then again
if you have large input arguments you're
duplicating those in memory so depending
on what it is that's causing the crash
you know as long as you're aware of how
things work try to you know try
different combinations
um
to adjust that overhead and or
duplication of things in memory
if that fails you know you can always
process things in batch with multiple
calls to childhood
um you also are going to want to be a
wary of data skew a single more complex
record can cause bottlenecks maybe even
crashes so potentially filter out such
records and handle them separately
and that's it for me you can find me on
LinkedIn and I will make this with
Republican I'll probably publish the
slides there as well
thank you